talked about no producer would want
someone to spend seven months editing a
film did you think it would take you
this long to finish the gospel no not at
all no I feel that the early predictions
were like a year and a half which go
well I think they were pretty you know
they were real realistic at all it took
much longer but again the project grew
much bigger than we thought you know at
the beginning of this was a short film
then turn out into a feature film and by
that point you know we thought it was
going just to be a film and it turned
out to be huge massive project with
thousands of people behind featuring
many many many places case study it is
good you know so we didn't care that was
taking longer than expected because on
the way we were learning so many things
about production distribution exhibition
of marketing filmmaking so for me it's
been like you know I dropped out of
university because I was getting bored
and learning nothing and in the last
four years I've learned like everything
that you learned during a 10 or 20 year
career like all at once or once and it
was there are things you come I
mean you can't teach how to direct a
film until you make it and they had the
chance to make it and you can't teach
how to the film until you edit it for
seven months and you discover what you
are doing wrong and what you're doing
right so yes it took longer than
expected i think all the experience it
gave us is invaluable it's like it's
amazing it's gonna you know we're going
to keep it for the list for the rest of
our life that's amazing which do you
think is worse overconfidence
over which is first it depends probably
under confidence I mean I think if you
are if you can manage your ego
overconfidence is amazing it's like you
know you everyone should have
overconfidence not thinking they are the
best guy in town but you know be sure
that what they do is good this book you
know keeps you going further and I'm
achieving things things get
overconfident Sookie but you know you
need to be very careful your ego because
that that that steps in the way of your
work and under confidence how does a
minimizer I think that under confidence
from prevents you from doing things just
like you know happens with everything
when you when you go out to date for
example you know if you have the
confidence that things are going to
happen they will probably happen if
you're you know aware that something
might go wrong or whatever you're not
gonna even try and this is very
Hollywood page thing to say but I think
it's important you know you need to
again remain honest and remain humble
but overconfidence is the best thing
that happened to you you need to try to
have it I guess
you